okay we're going to go ahead and get
started we're going to switch around the
order a little bit in order to
accommodate schedules but I want to give
a quick introduction to each of the
guests welcome thanks for coming this is
interactive city reading the metropolis
and I'm going to give a very short
introduction to work in conjunction with
my quickly deteriorating voice but when
David and I came up with the idea for
the symposium I thought the synthesis of
an introduction would be relatively easy
to talk about or easy to put together
John researches the potentials of
augmented reality Sarah creates GIS
mashups and called spatial data traces
Eric engages the public realm and info
scape directly in both traditional and
non-traditional architectural
interventions each speaker works at the
scale of the city but their work is
equally considerate of the body and
building so all the work is very
obviously relevant to even the most
traditional definition of architecture
and practice as an architect and while
there are countless ways that each of
the speakers could be you to tie the
three speakers work and research
together for me what's most interesting
is where the work doesn't overlap for me
it's the edges of their research and the
unique questions their work produce each
speaker is pushing the limits of their
practices mapmakers in one way or
another each speaker is a cartographer
for the contemporary condition of our
cities I use the term Mac mapmaker
because I think each speaker uses our
rapidly expanding visual culture in
order to give definition to the
immaterial constructs of our environment
in these formalization of the non
corporal they revealed the unknowable or
rather what was previously unknowable
this dialogue and formalization of the
info scape is the cost where the
potential for intervention and event in
vention is the greatest this is the
space where reaction realization and
change occur through the definition of
the definition of the immaterial our
previous understandings of the material
world can take on a different light this
different light can be cast in a variety
of ways that's dystopian perspective
frames previously inert constructs as
devices of control and oppression and
the utopium perspective reports that
technology will sis it will save us all
these vastly different readings reveal
the expanse potentials rife with in the
developing territory and unfortunately
the practice of architecture and the
architect is poised at the helm where
this opportunity seems limitless so the
first speaker tonight is going to be
Erik Heller Erik Heller is a registered
architect and the co founder and
principal of howler + architecture he
teaches at the GSD the Harvard's
Graduate School of Design in addition to
running his own practice and teaching
eric has published multiple book books
and has contributed to the journal
praxis prior to founding Heller Plus in
an architecture Erich was an associate
principal at kpf as well as a senior
designer at Dylan's video where I was
lucky enough to get to work with him in
addition to admiring their work and Eric
was asked to speak tonight because I
feel like the work he does in partners
in his partnership with me genuine
directly engages the developing dialogue
between the immaterial material forces
of our rapidly changing environment
specifically there what gives form to
immaterial to the immaterial challenging
traditional notions of boundary and
space while a number of avant-garde
practices are experimenting with this
contemporary condition what I think's a
bright color n you'ns work is the
research behind their interventions
critical to their work is an operative
understanding of the technological
ecological and social information
spaces where their work operates there's
this careful studying and understanding
of immaterial context they are able to
create architectural interventions which
engage the body building and even the
city in new and exciting ways air collar
okay thanks Josh thanks everybody for
sticking around the title reading the
city did you hear me ok said all right
ok so Josh us to respond to the theme of
reading the city which i think is quite
a provocative theme reading the city
suggested the city's a text that it can
be read that if you written that it
could be misread so I'm going to do two
things I'm going to show you some I'm
going to show you some projects but I'm
also going to sort of frame them through
a series of images this image you may
recognize that it's from city of glass
and it's ok
so I mean the question about reading the
city raises a couple of different
problems one the city you know
inevitably evokes the public realm and
the public realm and architecture seemed
to be sort of overlapping territories
how do we work on the public realm you
know I think the consensus is the public
rallies and just sort of there it's not
by default that I just we produce this
be constructed so some of the projects
that i'm going to show our projects
we've done in the public realm that are
somehow engaged in sort of constructing
this public condition and ultimately
producing a public in terms of an
audience inevitably it i think this is
interesting what ties into the themes in
this course are even as architecture
produces a public it also produces a
kind of representation so each project
are each agenda would sort of produce
its own as a by-product representations
this one i just started talking about
with from foster city of glass it is a
kind of trajectory through the city
which i'm sure you've read the book to
understand that it's actually some sort
of encrypted message that's actually
performed by a sort of traversing the
city the idea of reading the city evokes
for me a particular generation of
architects thinking about issues of
reading writing meaning things that were
talked about when i was in school and i
think that questions that postmodernism
we're so concerned with meaning and i
think we're going to see a kind of a
return to some of these
and significant I don't want to get into
a kind of architecture history but
images of the city and how the city sort
of is represented in this case a
one-point perspective produces its own
kinds of through the through the lens of
the type of representation it produces
different kinds of design and as I
transition from these kind of
introductory images to projects I'm
going to focus not just on reading the
city but writing the city and as
architects how do we project into the
city actively so not a kind of passive
reading but I kind of acted projection
other modes axonometric sort of removed
from the city sort of hovering above or
the kind of Noli plan the kind of famous
cut through the city and this is one of
the most sort of influential images that
come across in terms of representatives
city as the kind of fabric as a kind of
salad it's excavated I'm not sure you
come across this image you probably have
situations international proposed that
kind of reconfigurations to be based on
desire based on the senses based on a
kind of almost an accidental practice of
wandering
you know this isn't quite architecture
but we're so interested in the way that
these artists political activists sort
of reimagined city through their
activities through their situations but
also through their representations this
is Luke on sort of drawing traffic
patterns in Philadelphia so I think as
we try to think about how we're going to
read the city we also have to sort of
compass new terms to write to rewrite
the city and sound here I imagine you've
all come across these images is bernard
tschumi to manhattan transcripts looking
at film looking at scripps looking at
choreographies to try to find new ways
to produce architectures based on events
based on programs based on activities
and i think these were super influential
one when i was in school i think they're
probably still being reinvented and
rediscovered today obviously this and
then the question is what do these
representations produce or how do they
translate into printed projects or
someone like REM koolhaas researchers
and program and translating program or
event into into into proposal so finding
modes of representation how to represent
activity how to turn that into form I
think for a lot of REMS projects the
idea that the building is a city that is
attend microcosm of the city the
building then has urban elements
embedded in it thinking about it as a
Boulevard or moving through a building
you've probably also come across these
representations which are field
operations looking at phasing within
landscape and I think the early kind of
shoe me and OMA concerns with program an
event today I've sort of taken on new
meeting in terms of phasing and growth
with landscape urbanism
and a new interest in a kind of evolving
plan and the kind of temporal dimension
of a site plan which in a way I think it
also produces modes of representation
someone who was also quite influential
when we were in school standout so when
she was partner field operations was
talking from object of field and looking
at field conditions phenomena
atmospheres and all these things I think
are contributing to a kind of
understanding today of what the
architects role is is not just about
form it's not just about material but
it's a kind of much more expanded
understanding of designing an
environment I have a couple more slides
of sort of introductory images this
image you may not have seen this is vito
conchis project called following and in
a way it's a kind of mapping he chose as
a performance artist he chose to follow
person at random in the city as long as
he could and then when they went into a
private space stop following him so and
then find somebody else and he would
sort of follow them and through this
kind of bizarre almost creepy following
projects he he in a way he charted out
the territory which is to find this
public and i think that's it we've got a
really powerful way on a very small
scale you know one person sort of
mapping a city as a kind of performance
art piece so Vito I think for us as
architects but looking at Vito's
practice I think it's quite powerful you
know this kind of
visual map that's produced of the city
cindy sherman boy bridge I'm going to
skip through these probably quite
familiar right mapping bodies in space
is something that interests us as as
architects but also thinking about the
kind of intimate scale the body in the
city and it's different trajectories
it's different geometries you could sort
of describe the kind of space defined by
the body or the body in space somehow
suspended so I'm going to show you some
projects now that hopefully draw on some
of these reference images this is a
project we did early on in our practice
we were sort of my partner me genuine
design what was called the defensible
dress and the idea is your personal
space is is defined by different
parameters their cultural there there
may be urban and how do you produce a
garment that acts as a kind of
architecture that defines that sort of
territory around the body so this was
one of our first sort of geek projects
where we actually took components
sensors to to create this dress it
actually uses a smart material it's a
nitinol wire which contracts when it has
a bunch of current running through
and in a combination with a couple of
simple hinges and a sensor when this so
there's that's the wire right there
that's the sensor and that's an LED
because the microcontroller so when the
sensor perceives an intruder a body
presence essentially a differential heat
condition it triggers the night know it
runs Corinth you might know and then the
sort of porcupine dress sort of
activates and this project was something
we did early on and just sort of
understanding the relationship between
some of these simple components sort of
electronic components and their capacity
to transform space in this case of the
personal space of a dress and actually
that project led to other projects this
is one project that we did for the
athens olympics it was called white
noise white light we've proposed it in a
competition to create a field of lights
that would respond to the to the viewer
we had no idea how to do this but we
thought okay let's let's propose it and
they accepted it and then we had to
figure out how to how to realize it but
we had some ideas on so these are the
kind of concept images there's a field
you move through the field you trigger
the lights and not just white light but
also white noise so it has a kind of
kind of soundtrack to it i'm just going
to show you a quick video
so they're fiber optics stocks fiber
optics
attached to housing waterproof housing
which has the same microcontroller and
still when it's figured it lights up and
it
trail in the city and this was installed
in Athens during the Olympics basically
properly
city way the white noise actually
produces the kind of kind of different
spaces
Jai Sri out to demonstrate the behavior
of the field by moving from left to
right this case
but what we learned about this project
was it you could set up
ultimately used and we thought that was
actually kind of powerful powerful thing
to set in motion a series of events that
people would sort of take over and sort
of take take possession of so the way
that was done here is a sort of drawing
there's a wooden deck there's the
housing piece there's a metal flange and
a fiber optic stock and again we've did
some custom electronics here with the
microcontroller and the speaker we
worked with an electronics engineer to
sort of produce this and then we did all
the sweatshop assembling ourselves here
learning how to solder put them together
and then shipping them out there's an
engineer prototype and this is on site
someday so at the beginning when we
start our practice we realized that some
of these things they didn't really have
a kind of normative sort of precedent
there were things that we thought Oh
wouldn't it be interesting if we could
make a space in the city where you could
lose yourself from the city where things
responded to you and then we sort of set
out to figure out how these things
worked and and as architects try to
figure out the detailing the material
and the logistics of implementing
something like this we also noticed as
we became interested in the idea of
publicness and publix but there was
something going on in terms of the
public realm and if you were in New York
during 911 and right afterwards and even
today I think you feel a different sense
of publicness when you're outside and
and I think what we've become interested
in is the idea that the public realm is
not accidental it's actually it is a
political space that is something
that is charged it's loaded and your
behavior within it it's not only it's
none of these surveyed but is actually
scripted and I think social codes sort
of dictate how you behave in certain in
certain situations so that something we
became interested in this idea of
control within the public round
obviously there's sort of material
involved there's a lot of sort of
information and the material like in
this case of jersey barrier is then
overlaid with this kind of you know red
white and blue so it's sort of caught up
in the kind of political we became
interested in these questions of
visibility vision power control
surveillance pleasure you know in this
case the idea of surveillance in
paranoia sort of turned on its head the
idea of calling attention to something
through through this sort of hyper hyper
attenuated attention in the security
cameras so we noticed these things
happening in the city around us and we
sort of folded some of these ideas into
this project this is project we did in
DC called low res hi-fi DC by the way is
one of the most sort of barricaded
cities in the country we can imagine
this is two blocks and three blocks
north to the White House I'm vermont
avenue this is a developer project the
developer said this is my site and you
make a public realm here and you sort of
animate the sidewalk and i said okay
maybe we should incorporate some sort of
public art piece news some signage maybe
some lighting maybe some interactive
architecture so we did two things we did
this thing on the right which is a sort
of what we call the sound grove which is
the kind of series of touch sensitive
musical instruments and on the on the
right this was a piece of building
signage which doubles as a kind of
public art piece that's actually out in
the sidewalk we're thinking about again
we're thing about Vito and his project
where he was shadowboxing with himself
and we thought it would be interesting
to get people to behave like this in the
city you know in the street to sort of
engage their own their own body gonna
kind of playful way so the LED net that
we design actually became a kind of
digital shadow project we're not to sort
of you know we're not producing real
shadow were feeding surveillance footage
into the screen so the idea was that we
take the existing surveillance we put it
into the screen and that would be
overlaid with the building address so in
this case address is 11 10 vermont
avenue the ones and zeros became a kind
of field condition and then the overlay
was the body sort of on top of that on
top of that graphic oops so we developed
the pixel net it's not something that we
could buy off the shelf so again we sort
of went out and and worked with an
electronics engineer to custom
fabricators these pixels I'll show you
another video of this what it's like so
there's the building address there's a
shadow there's me startled maybe I can
shadow box with this thing maybe I can
sort of white out this is text anyways
it it is a commercial project i mean the
developer wanted the sign for his
address and in a way we felt like we
managed to smuggle some sort of
interactive behavior into something that
was by default condition was already
kind of piece of commercial branding for
this for this development so we sort of
had some get some fun with that you know
we had some questions about it's sort of
commercial quality but in a way I think
that's how you get things done you have
to sort of find ways to find mechanisms
for intervening within the city weather
finding it yourself or you're finding a
developer that will support something
like this the rd involves the
development of the pixel here's a
two-sided pixel it's suspended on a on a
wire and the wire actually supports it
it also provides power and it also
addresses it so it's sending a signal
and in a way it produces the screen and
into that screen we can broadcast in any
content so once it's up we can sort of
change its content a lot of the
fabrication was done ourselves again we
provided the sweatshop labor this is the
engineer Bill Pickering and parallel
development and I've gone by and I've
seen people sort of behaving strangely
in front of it they're sort of you know
trying to I'm trying to interact with
this piece so I kind of think that's in
a way sign of success the other part
that like the sound Grove is the
stainless steel poles in this case we
didn't use infrared sensors is the
capacity sensors so basically you're
your body has a kind of electrical
charge to it and that electrical charge
disrupts and causes the triggers a
sensor so we worked with a sound
composer to develop these different
sounds and within this we sort of
invented ways to sort of communicate a
network of different sounds different
instruments different
once they're all network
them
playback dream state previous
top of things
fun with it scripted some of these
scenarios come and touch things and move
around we actually documented it very
seriously with a video camera but we
went out there one day and found people
playing with it and actually I found
stuff on YouTube which is hilarious I'll
show you
we're not
technical second folders will apologize
I mean that's you know where that's
found found footage people actually
interacting with the thing where she can
is always kind of surprising and it's
nice to see people sort of take over
take over piece like that and then the
Thursday will leave it as I'm kind of
open an open system where I can be just
appropriate by different people and
having done a few of these now we're
sort of figuring out what it is that
people would find just sort of playful
and feeling about some of these
environments okay keep going another
project that we did is similar we've
been sort of getting calls to do repeat
projects like this in spaces whether
they're public spaces or pseudo public
spaces like lobbyists this was another
Commission in Washington DC for a kind
of dynamic art wall and we've been doing
so much with electronics but we wanted
to sort of deal with physical material
so we took glass and we sort of credit
we sort of compound curved surface cut
it stacked it like this and it produces
sort of panel in the lobby and then
every piece of glass is independently
computer controlled with RGB lighting so
again a kind of custom circuit board
again some sort of programming of the
behavior of this thing and then the end
it produces a kind of an animated
material so the material this is all
glass it's all n stacked leather stacked
up and then we're just sort of
controlling a behavior of the lights as
it sort of scrolls up and down so again
this is pretty low res in terms of
behavior and it's pretty crude but in a
way I think the suggestion is that it
could produce modes of sort of animating
animating space and material
something that we're sort of looking at
further another project in the animation
world we were trying to we're interested
in this concept of entices which is
they're kind of in a classical column
the kind of perceptual sort of swelling
in the in the shaft of the column we
produce these physical study models of
columns in space and we wanted to
computer control the rotation to produce
a series of swells and bulges so the two
columns sort of interact with each other
through the servo motor that controls
them at the top it's again the
interaction between material in this
case polypropylene and information in
this case observe programming of the
servo motor and this was part of the
matters of stations at RT space which
was about sort of material rediscovering
material through digital fabrication in
this case yes it was digitally
fabricated but the interest here was
really in the kind of capacity to
animate this material to sort of predict
this behavior and ultimately give each
of these columns in a way a kind of
almost a personality in terms of the
speed of rotation and it kind of the
configuration of material and how it
would sort of swell to produce the kind
of variable sort of passageway between
them
similarly everything but architecture is
as not just material but actually as
atmosphere or environment we did a small
project in New Orleans looking at in the
center of the city bring people back to
the center city we proposed a canopy
that would be luminous and it would be
lit with solar solar panels so the panel
would sort of charge during the day at
nighttime I would I would sort of
consume the energy but it had sort of
stored up and in a way that would index
the like quality during the day so this
is the flexible photovoltaic battery and
a rope light this was a new orleans and
the geometry was sort of sculpted such
that it would face optimal orientation
for new orleans in december which is
like that again we did all the sweatshop
labor ourselves programming with our
engineer to regulate the light output
the geometry is the pentagonal tile
that's going through the rounded cone
shape is just to kind of loft and then
the bias is introduced to it oriented
so
fabric cut out annals the studio during
production sewing testing installation
see those solar panels there and then it
produced the kind of ambient sort of
environment which wasn't dynamic wasn't
responsive but it just sort of measured
and I think it broadcasted a kind of
condition that energy can be sort of
produced locally and consumed equally
locally so it was sort of starting to
think about how do we talk about issues
of energy issues of space issues of
place making through these kind of
atmospheric environment more projects
this one was a proposal for the Kennedy
Center in DC starting to think about
sort of local energy production and
consumption and trying to get people to
become aware of the kind of abundance of
sort of natural energy renewable energy
everywhere you know the flows around the
Kennedy Center it's got a lot of
exposure we thought we could sort of
visualize those flows through a series
of wind turbines that would be
generating power locally and sort of
emitting light so these are the proposal
rendering it's just showing a pattern of
light and ornamental screen it doesn't
store energy it just consumes it
immediately and somehow calls attention
to the to that source so in the debates
about wind power particularly in
Massachusetts and Cape Cod this the
arguments are always aesthetic you know
yes you want power clean power but no we
don't like the way those things look so
we thought maybe we could redesign some
of the some of those turbines
through a series of studies trying to
figure out where to put the generator
and how to integrate the lighting to
produce ultimately a kind of screen like
an ornamental screen that's sort of
dynamic and sort of continuously
charging and consuming energy
I grab this water
I wanted to talk a little bit about an
idea about research and the public realm
we do the small projects we also do
buildings but I'm showing mostly public
space projects part of that you know
involves some R&D in terms of technology
but also I think what's been interesting
for us is to engage the idea of the
public realm as a project and how do we
as architects not just worried about the
buildings but actually worried about
that space between the buildings and all
the territory that comes with it so
recently in Boston the Big Dig was
completed the Big Dig as you may know is
an urban tunnel sort of sinking a
highway under the under the under series
of parks and so we saw this thing we saw
the sort of construction sort of recede
and then we saw the emergence of this
new public realm but we found it sort of
underwhelming and so we sort of took on
this as a book project we sort of did
some research about its history Boston
and it's sort of evolving coastline this
was the raised highway the two parts of
the city that was sort of split in two
and so we discovered something about our
own backyard in a way we didn't have to
go to to Nigeria or Lagos or you know
Shanghai to do kind of urban studies
look that side this is the paradox there
is a highway 12 lanes running underneath
the city there's a pristine sort of
pastoral landscape on top of it and
the feeling was that this would
reconnect the city but we felt that this
was somehow not sufficient and so it
didn't acknowledge the fact that this
was an incredible sort of technological
achievement this is actually
infrastructure it's not landscape so we
looked at that we sort of cataloging the
who's hard to figure out how it was done
because it's really sort of incredible
how it's done and then we did a series
of projects that would sum up comment on
this condition that's kind of fake
pastoral what we call you know the post
pastoral and all the infrastructure that
comes with it including and the
ambitions for it you know it wants to be
simultaneously guarded it once was
animal taneously highway and sort of
recreational surfaces so we propose a
try panel ground condition that could be
sort of flipped you know to a comment he
was different sort of competing uses we
catalogued all the kind of surveillance
infrastructure the lighting
infrastructure we looked at the fact
that all this expenditure was primarily
for the car but not for the pedestrian
and so the surface sort of surface
inhabitants we're sort of left out of
that so we propose that kind of some
sort of easy pass and going a shoe and
as a pedestrian is reconfigure the
landscape to allow you to pass we looked
at the bent structures for exhausting
the tunnels and we proposed gather
electric sort of Porcupine too hard and
some of the energy that's produced as
the event is exhausting exhausting air
last project I want to show you is a
kind of playful project we did for
Boston as you know the economy's left
all kinds of sites in cities empty this
kind of vacancies in the city you're
kind of a glaring sort of index of their
kind of failed economy and we're asked
to make some proposals for what to do
with these sites so this is the fighting
site in Boston which used to have the
basement in it and it got torn down and
the tower that was supposed to go there
the funding evaporated so what could we
put there almost instantaneously and we
look back at some of our heroes like our
to grant an idea of an instant city or
kind of robotic reconfigurable City we
proposed a allergy bioreactor obviously
that would sort of reconfigure itself to
optimize itself for growth the feeling
was that when the funding actually comes
back this thing could be dismantled when
we reinstalled somewhere else so here
the kind of robotic arms we actually got
a lot of phone calls from people that
were interested in growing algae and we
actually had some scientists come from
Australia visit us to tell us about how
you do this I'm going to show you a
quick little fun video that's somebody
else
so this was something it was highly
speculative and playful and fun and
urban and and then I think we have to
sort of take the initiative to sort of
generate somebody's project it's stuck
again okay so what I want to say I want
to say as architects you know the public
realm is something that isn't just sort
of beyond your proper lighting something
that you have to produce its produce not
just to sort of physical material means
that actually combination and
information here a lot more about that
information lighting atmospherics and
the interactions with some material and
immaterial repertoire of effects as well
maybe this is another place so maybe
I'll just
so our next speaker as good tonight is
Sarah Williams Sarah is currently the
director of Columbia spatial information
design lab her research focuses on
representation of digital information
and mapping and ecological design and
planning she teaches in the visual
studies program here at Columbia who
will be offering her workshop field to
play agency and mapping site this fall
semester before Columbia Sarah was at
MIT where she started the geographic
information systems GIS laboratory and
worked at the sensible city laboratory a
joint program between the MIT Media Lab
and the Department of Urban Studies and
planning sarah has a background in
geography landscape urban design and
urban planning and this blend of those
and disciplines I think gives her a
unique perspective today she's going to
talk to you about mapping the immaterial
and material information space of the
city Sarah's work I think definitively
lies in that sort of zone where we as
architects used to do our mappings and
categorize everything is unknowable and
therefore we did our mappings from
empirical data and usually based on
preconceived ideas about the city and
then we went and designed a building
based on that same preconceived idea
about the city and made sure that the
mapping verified the building and
forwards and backwards well Sarah
actually has real science and data
behind the mappings that she beats it's
sort of erasing the architects ability
to use our once highly powerful tool of
smoke and mirrors so and now that now
that she's erased our ability to use
smoke and mirrors she has to show us how
to
to generate real data in real maps with
concrete results sir so as just said I
run the spatial information design lab
here at Columbia and the lab focuses on
a methodological approached to use data
about places to expose social and
environmental issues that might not have
otherwise been seen and we do this
through something I have I think that's
a little bit different from some of the
other labs here at Columbia really use
we're interested in quantitative
analysis geographic representation and
visualization so at the lab we really
try to take as just that actual data
quantify it and actually do spatial
analysis statistical results but then
actually make compelling visualizations
out of those so that we can be both
scientific and that our data can uphold
a scientific rigor but also it can
present a compelling message so one of
the things I thought about when I heard
that title for this lecture today is um
you know I'm originally trained as a
geographer and we always think about
problems as they relate to space and
proximity that's kind of the basis of
what geographers are and more
importantly we think about how place
plays a role and how we develop society
so I thought it would be interesting to
put this quote up at the beginning of
the lecture to talk about actually I'm
one of the famous geographers from the
1800's said that Myrnin's and places are
not geography most people think
geography is about names and places and
such
yourself within within that it's
actually not that it constitutes anyone
geography has higher aims than this it
seeks to classify phenomena a like of
the nature and the political world
insofar as it treats the latter to
compare to generalized to ascend from
the effects and causes and in doing so
to trace out the great laws of nature
and to mark their influence and pom man
this is the description of the world
that is geography and the world
geography is science a thing not of mere
names but of argument and reason and
then cause of effect and I hadn't really
think that's how I see a lot of the
projects that we do of the love I'm
always trying to look at new types of
data but what can they tell us about
cause and effects in the city and so
when I was thinking about the topic
today Interactive City reading the
metropolis I thought about how I'm
always looking at the city for cues that
would allow me as Hugh's would put it to
compare generalize and ascend from
effects and causes to understand the
systems at play in the city and how the
effects of spatial form also affects
spatial patterns in other words I'm
always reading the metropolis as I think
most of us are as architects and
planners and designers I think that's
that's why we're here but um and I think
I'm pretty interactive too but but I
don't think that's why Josh asked me to
come speak so what I wanted to talk
about is a research area that I've been
or an area of research that I've been
writing about for the last several years
which is something that I call spatial
data traces and this is the did
information register by place that we
leave behind as we interact with the
digital environment and so when we swipe
our subway card we leave information
about where we are when how long we were
there where we're going to when we use
our cell phone we're leaving bits of
information about who we called where we
call who were talking to and this is
becoming more prominent recently with
new cell phone applications that
specifically target positioning yourself
within the urban environment when we use
wireless internet we're connecting to
certain locations and we're doing this
in certain places and we're connecting
to a certain places at certain locations
etc these all have kind of a place-based
specificity surveillance cameras also
mark and trace us as we move through the
urban environment and new location based
services applications have been more
developed specifically to target this
kind of what I call spatial data traces
Foursquare or God go Willa or where are
all actually asking participants to
actively leave their traces about
themselves so how can these spatial data
traces be used to analyze the cities is
what I'm interested in and one of the
things that I thought about when Josh
asked me to give the lectures is how do
i how do i classify these different data
types these different data traces is a
framework for for setting up the lecture
and I think there's three main types of
data there's process data I've curated
data and something I call self
registered data and I think each data
type allows you to talk or say something
different about the city and so I'm
going to use examples from
research in the lab kind of explain what
I mean by that to process data is the
intent of the datas on the part of the
individual is very low so the collection
just kind of happens as you're moving
through the environment the individual
who's leaving their trace might not
really be aware that that's happening
the organization and collection is
systematic and highly automated and the
trace is hidden and the barrier to
access is high and so I'm going to talk
about what I what I mean by that through
through the projects and come back to it
but I think process data really equals
kind of the pulse of the city because
it's it's kind of data that we're
leaving behind as we're moving through
the city and we're not necessarily aware
that we're leaving that information so a
great example is looking at the bits of
information that we leave behind for
cell phones and this is a project that i
actually did with the sensible cities
lab where we looked at cell phone data
and we had something that look like this
this is a cellphone record it has a ID
tower as a day of the week it has where
we were connected to this is a project
was done in milan italy and this is
actually an image of all the towers cell
phone towers in milan at the time that
we did the project and what we had were
was a database that told us each cell
phone user how they were connected to
different towers so these would
represent three different cell phone
towers and the angle in which they were
connected to that tower and what that
allowed you to do is actually to
triangulate the position within 50
meters and so you could figure out the
position of the person using the cell
phone at that occasion we were able to
map those users and then create a series
of maps in the city of Milan and so this
is actually
on train station at 4pm 5pm 6pm 7pm 8pm
and what you can see is that something
we might already know the train station
is really busy during rush hour but I
think what it also tells you is kind of
discreet places in the city that become
active at different types of day it
gives us the flow of the city there's no
other place where we have recording or
marking of where people are we have a
census which marks people by where they
live we have a economic census that
marks people by where they work but we
don't have anything that kind of tells
us how the city operates on the hourly
basis we also did this in a region we
had this data regionally so we did it 8
p.m. through about 1pm in the morning
rush hour and what you could see this is
milan city center and what you can see
is that obviously people are moving into
the city if the day the day goes on so
what so what does this mean who cares
like we mapped things that we already
might know we mapped the ability to see
rush hour but stuff on processed data
can tell us a lot about urban flows with
applications and advertising Emergency
Management and so forth one of the
reasons that Vodafone was interested in
having us map this data Vodafone was the
company who released the data to us is
because they were interested in
advertising location-based services
where to target advertisements in the
city at given times of the day but also
Milan's city managers were really
interested in it for thinking about
emergency events really practical kinds
of things about how to distribute
information about you know like if there
was a bomb part of the city where would
you want to
direct people just understanding that
kind of thing but also transportation
analysts are very interested in this
type of data in order to better manage
transport systems direct traffic that
kind of thing oh so here's Milan between
four and eight and you can see how kind
of it's a kind of an inverse between the
two there's very similar project that I
just wanted to highlight because it was
recently in the New York Times and
people might have seen it but in New
York City all the cabs have gps units in
them and the New York Times did a very
similar kind of mapping which I think
that talks about the flow in this city
as well loaded up how many people saw
this let us go over quickly I just what
they did is they actually worked with
the taxicab agency and they got all the
GPS data for all the taxi cabs in New
York and they were actually able to look
at end of the flow in the city and there
be both feet they were able to begin to
talk about some patterns that they they
saw so kind of what we all know is the
lower east side comes to life after work
and stays in 28 hours so here's some
highlight of that Bloomingdale's and so
it's kind of a proxy for understanding
how how we navigate the city in a way
that we haven't had before here's a map
of tulsi actually so process data can
help us understand process pattern
which which in turn can tell us about
human behavior how people operate so
another process oriented our data that I
would categorize as process oriented is
something when you interact with city
services right you might login
information about yourself if you're
going to child services or to an
employment or any of those types of
things and this project we actually took
the process data associated with the
criminal justice system to tell us
something about that and we had
information about all the dresses of
where people lived before they went into
prison and how long they were going to
be incarcerated to get an idea of how
much it costs to incarcerate people in
the city so the data came to us like
this and we had addresses and we were
able to geo locate those addresses to
see where those people lived in the city
and then we added about buck laibach
sorry 359 million dollars to imprison
people from Brooklyn in a year and we
mapped those block by block in the city
so this is prison expenditures in
specimens dollar so these red blocks
highlight those places where just in one
single city block over a million dollars
was spent to incarcerate people from
that fat block so data in a geographic
contact shows that people in prison are
highly concentrated in neighborhood
areas while crime is more dispersed
across the city this is actually a map
of prison emission density versus crime
density that we developed out of this
project from a democratic view this
spending facilitate a mass migration of
people to prison 95% who eventually
returned home and
and this drawing we actually took each
location of a prisoner and connected
them to the prison that they eventually
ended up in so this is the migration
that you see so if you zoom in to some
of these communities community district
16 has 3.5 percent of Britain's
population in eight point five percent
of his prison emissions so this is
community district 16 and when you see
these blocks you can see that almost 12
million dollars was spent to incarcerate
people in 2003 and we call these
million-dollar blocks and so on a
financial scale prison is becoming the
predominant governing institution in the
neighborhood but for lack of investment
in resettlement up to forty percent of
those who come home or eventually return
to prison so what if more resources were
organized around settlement them around
displacement how would these parts of
the city look different so in this case
we took process data I have turned it on
its head and we said what if we can
illustrate how much money is being spent
to kind of send people away from prison
but what if when they returned home when
they return home they don't have the
resources so the same amount of money is
not being spent on education or job
training programs or housing or health
care for their kids what if just one
million dollars from those blocks was
spent to think about those city services
and to kind of look at that and so
instead of migrating people to these
prisons what about thinking about
resettlement patterns within the city
so I'm going to move to what I call
curated data and in curated data we
think about the tenth of the part of the
individual is guided by that of an
institution the organization and
collection is systematic and manual and
the trace is hidden or visible and the
barrier to access is low to medium so
what do I mean by that well a good
example is a curator is photographer who
collects images and what is the biggest
image collection agency Getty photo
images collects foot photographs that
are done redistributed to media outlets
and their main reason for curating data
is really to sell to the median so I
think it's an important point with when
you think about curated data is what is
the intent of the curation why are they
curating because it can tell you a lot
about what the results are so what we
did is actually we mined the Getty image
database for all the image tags for arts
and culture and we were able to win the
photographer logs their images into the
database they actually say where a
picture was taken and the cake kind of
categorize it into some kind of format
and we were able to map these images
this is actually Los Angeles of the arts
and culture events and so this is what
this is one of the images that we
produce from it but these are some of
the events that that were produced when
we called for arts and culture so I
guess UCLA premieres in hollywood
word so for this is kind of another
image we produce of that in Los Angeles
and this project we call the geography
of us are visualizing cultural space in
New York and Los Angeles and this is
actually image that we generated of arts
events in the city and actually the peak
is over MoMA here which is something so
this project came out of a collaboration
with my colleague Elizabeth pirard who
wrote the Warhol economy and what she
talks about and this book is really
about how the clustering of social scene
or the clustering of social events in
arts and culture economy is what makes
it really successful so as proximity
matters as much as proximity matters in
Silicon Valley and that people who work
in arts and culture need to socialize to
get their business done and so our
database looked like something like this
after we called the Getty Images this is
we would have an event name we had the
address that we then geocoded and then
what we did is once we had all the
events we coated them into different
typologies of Arts and Culture
television film something we called
magnet because a lot of the images in
the Getty image database which are
considered arts and culture are really
like Britney Spears birthday party kind
of famous soccer stars birthday party or
event or kind of just parties in general
so we titled those magnet events and
their fashion events music events and
arts events and we performed once we
mapped all these events we actually
perform spatial analysis
we ran something called the Geddes org
or g-star hotspot statistic that looked
whether there was statistical
significance in the clustering of
certain events so these are the outputs
from the clustering and so this is our
film music television theater of fashion
in New York and these same categories in
Los Angeles and what we found is you
know what you might think film events
cook cluster together and they cluster
around the kodak theater here in Los
Angeles and in new york city we also see
a clustering of theater events where you
might think of it in the theater
district we also sell clustering of
television events around rockefeller
center where there's a lot of media and
so forth but there were some unexpected
things that that we saw him one of those
was fashion we couldn't figure out why
is fifth avenue such a hot spot for her
fashion well because it's traditionally
a hot spot for fashion in terms of that
iconic nature of the city right the
Tiffany's the idea of Tiffany's and kind
of the madison avenue stores
high-end stores we also saw that anomaly
in Los Angeles this is actually Beverly
Hills this is the Sunset Strip Hollywood
Boulevard and then again this is the
kodak theater area out in hollywood and
so what we realized is actually a lot of
what we were a lot of the clustering
patterns that we were seeing illustrated
or kind of followed along what we saw at
the magnet events when we did that so
this kind of center line through los
angeles was very big Holly both folder
at Sunset Strip weird a drive and then
in New York City we saw something
similar Fifth Avenue Times Square was a
hot spot meatpacking west village and we
caught this event enclaves and I think
what we thought when we set out to do
this project is that we would see kind
of the places where arts and culture or
socialize using kind of the getty images
as our proxy to do that but what we
actually realize is that we came up with
the places that mass media markets as
for these places so if you look at
Sunset Boulevard Hollywood beverly hills
were kind of hotspots in LA Fifth Avenue
Midtown and the Meatpacking or hotspots
in New York City and what this is really
telling us is that the Getty image
database is really it highlights how
media uses space to sell products so
most of these events are really about
selling a different kind of product and
they use kind of the iconic nature of
the city to sell those products so why
is time square so highlighted in these
maps because Times Square was what
represents New York to a global
marketplace and different products want
to be associated with that global
marketplace and so what I think was
really interesting about the Getty image
study is that it highlighted how media
use spaces or how media uses
in the city um so curated data
highlights the interests of the data
collectors so in this case Getty and so
it really says how medium promoters have
an effect on space so event enclaves are
times square and the kodak theatre
they're not maybe the places that New
Yorkers are from Los Angeles hang out in
but they do sell this city and they sell
the products that that want to be
associated with that city in the terms
of curated data curation can happen to
make a statement as well and so in this
project we actually collected our own
data and we collected data about air
quality these are some of the initial
traces that we collected and this was a
project that started when I was in
Beijing in 2004 and this is the image
that i saw on tanaman square and i
thought how are they going to have
olympics here with this type of smog so
this is actually beijing in 2008 very
similar slog conditions and so we wanted
to see how we could use data to expose
air quality issues or use kind of
mapping of data traces to expose the air
quality conditions in China so we teamed
up with The Associated Press we created
sensors that were attached to cell
phones and we measured air quality and
we had the Associated Press reporters
actually measure the air quality for us
because we weren't able to get into all
the venues also The Associated Press had
cell phones that they were given so we
were able to make a program that would
operate on all the presses cell phone so
that they could attach this answer to
any cell phones and then distribute the
information this is actually another
reporter measuring
that green um so these mobile sensors
have a GPS component and a sensor
component we measured particular matter
and carbon monoxide and we've measured
the particular matter because of its
regional effects particular matter and
also because it was of the highest
concern for how for health issues with
athletes particular that matter is the
fine dust that gets into athletes lungs
and and is one of the biggest concerns
but also a particular matter can travel
long distances and so one of the things
that the Chinese government did during
the Olympics as they shut down factories
90 miles from outside Beijing and they
did a factory closures within the city
the carbon monoxide we chose because it
had a more has a much more localized
effect / muxo doesn't travel very far
but they are also were specific mandates
that the Chinese government put in place
at that time they wanted to remove about
3.3 million cars from the road so all
these are components of smog we couldn't
measure all the components of smog but
we decided to pick these two because we
felt like they would be most
representative of the regional and
localized effect of air quality and how
Beijing responded to air quality was
during the Olympics so we set out to
measure daily at the Olympic Park
tenement square tempo of heaven we also
had the idea that our reporters would be
just kind of mobile with these devices
throughout the Olympics but we had a
problem with security for the press
people and that they were being
questions about the devices and so forth
so we had to because they were actually
illegal
I guess you're not you're not allowed to
have GPS units in that anyways so we had
to modify that a little bit and the
press did one thing where they did a
daily tour of the Olympic green and they
also did a daily picture this is
actually a graphic that the associated
press created from the data that was a
result of that so they took a picture in
front of the green every year and then
this is the Olympic dreams in this case
there was 600 micrograms per cubic meter
the World Health standard is 50
micrograms and if you compare it to New
York which is this yellow one in Los
Angeles you can see that the air quality
is much higher this is another graphic
we produce to try to kind of get at the
air quality just a few weeks before
opening day there was five hundred and
eighty four micrograms sort of 18 high
times higher than New York City opening
day of the Olympics was 13 times higher
just two days after opening days it was
25 times higher but then there was
actually a day where it was lower than
New York City and I don't know if you
guys remember the Olympics but it
started to rain towards the end and rain
dissipates the particulate matter this
is another chart of that same data and
you can see the low levels at the
Olympic start vs. towards the end where
they were much lower but you can see
that they're pretty consistently higher
than what you would see here in New York
City but we really wanted these devices
to be mobile and although we had a lot
of security problems basically a lot of
the reporters that we gave these two
were photographers and some of the
photographers were known to take
pictures where they didn't
too so they kept being taken in by some
of the police and they were worried if
they had these devices that they might
be arrested so we kind of limited some
of the things but we did we were able to
do one of our mobile things that we
really wanted to see how the air quality
was along the marathon route so we set
out our reporter who this poor reporter
became the last person who was really on
the prospect to make it did a lot of the
mobile sensing his face does not look
happy about leaving for another trip
through Beijing in the muggy weather and
we did the same thing in New York City
and we did the marathon route and this
is actually the result of that we did
actually two in Beijing one before the
car mandate was put in place and one
after and what we found was that there
was in some cases it decreased by half
of the carbon monoxide and we found that
carbon monoxides were very similar to
those found in New York City and so some
ways we think that perhaps the local men
the removing cars from the road help to
decrease carbon monoxide on the roads in
Beijing and actually that mandate is
still in place today the Beijing
government was happy with it and
actually citizens or disturbed by the
decrease in so they've actually kept
that mandate in place so it's hard to
say um you know whether the air quality
got bad better because of some of the
measures they made but you can see this
is opening day this is the second
weekend and this is last weekend so you
can't see the air quality over the
course of the Olympics did improve so
curated data data can highlight the
interests of the data collectors so in
this case we expose air quality by
curating
certain type of information in this case
curating air quality so finally and i
think i'm coming to end of my time and
i'll just go through this quickly is
some of the new projects that we're
looking at is self registered data and
this is the intent and the part of the
individual is high and the organization
eccleston collection is non-systemic in
that people are just volunteering
information willy-nilly kind of there's
mixed manual search based tags and
traces visual and buried to access as
well so examples of this is kind of
really twitter and i would say self
registered data are like rumors the more
they are collected the more they
describe so when I'm talking about self
registry data i'm talking about twitter
i'm talking about foursquare i'm talking
about all kinds of sites google earth
that you can begin to mark your
information about what you observe or
see in the environment but how can we
use that information so self registered
data needs high numbers of collective
information registration to describe or
discern patterns when this is more
getting back to what Josh was saying if
you want to be scientific about the
statistics that you find obviously you
can take a lot of this self registered
data and make some kind of assumptions
of it but if you want to make something
statistical out of a you really need
high numbers and some research has been
done the number one flickr picture
there's the Eiffel Tower so or the
number one flickr tourist location is
New York City and these are actually
traces of Flickr users within the the
city of New York this study actually
looks at all the kind of Maine pictures
that are taken in Flickr and what's them
most highlighted kind of attraction so
what can this what can you do with this
data
maybe in this example you could use our
create a self-generating tour guide
based on the type of information you
download but you can make observations
about spaces in the city places that
people like to observe paste people at
hang out places that are important to
people who are registering that
information other kinds of sites that do
this now or this is trend map which
looks at all the current trends on
Twitter so this was actually it's text
grab this this afternoon this was our
trend it was rainy and there was thunder
and people needed a I'm brow so this can
help us describe kind of physical
conditions in the environment and kind
of taken as a whole I can describe a
kind of feeling about a place or an
emotion and I think what's interesting
about self registered data is that the
fact that it's a less tangible in terms
of accuracy allows it to it provides a
more kind of emotional setting for the
city what are people feeling on Twitter
or what are what is the current
condition of the place that you're
operating and so this is kind of where
we're looking at research now we have
couple grants that are looking at kind
of how these different data sets can
tell us about the emotional or social
qualities of the city and this is
actually something that I thought people
might be
taking a number of these sites or square
um say the least but what it helps us in
so all these sites actually provide
their data through their api's and they
can all tell us a lot about kind of the
activity in the city and I think that
using these sites to tell us about how
we operate in the city is going to
become increasingly important to city
managers so this is another site so how
can this spatial data for trace be
analyzed to the city I hope I gave some
idea of that but what does it mean that
we have all this data at our fingertips
what does it mean that we have data from
Foursquare or we have it's much easier
to get cell phone information or that we
volunteer all this data I think it can
tell us a lot about how to rethink
policy in this city so if you think
about the million-dollar blocks project
it can really help us to question about
where money's being spent in the Getty
Images project it can really tell you
how media affects space we never think
about media promoters as participants in
space development yet they are there
promoting kind of the whole time square
and it's kind of a media promotion and
highlighting that and thinking about
what that means for urban development
and policy but what does it mean that we
just kind of volunteer all this
information how to cities use it for
crowdsourcing purposes for efficiency
purposes for management
this is so I think I wanted to leave
with that question maybe we could
discuss it on the panel thanks Sarah
those great and the interest of time
i'll keep this introduction very short
our next speaker is John havens he's a
VP of social media Gordon aveli and
author of the book tactical transparency
how leaders can leverage social media to
maximize value and build their brand
John's going to speak us today about
augmented reality with that I'll turn it
over to John thank you how you doing
anybody
so I'll just say it up front am SBP of
social media Porter Novelli were a
global PR firm the social media geek i
worked at about.com about five years ago
when it was called new media and I've
been preaching it for about four or five
years that people should use social
media to have commerce advertising
whatever and I'm very interested I was
an actor for about 15 years I did
Broadway TV and film lon owner and a lot
of that type of stuff I'm very
interested to see where Commerce and art
mix I think a lot of times the best
shows that I ever saw you know like a
lot of people here you know east side in
the village or something you see this
amazing artistic shows but then they
don't get to be seen by a larger scale
because they don't have money behind
them so I think what's interesting is
rather than demonize how a certain
technology comes into being not that
anyone here is demonizing that I'm just
saying that there we go
anyway a lot of the most formative work
on augmented reality Esther started here
at Columbia so I'm going to move beyond
that potential tension that I may
describe something incorrect and just if
you don't know about augmented reality I
want to give a couple of quick examples
the top left is called or as a webcam
based augmented reality you've probably
seen pretty often what this person is
holding in their hand is what's called
an augmented reality marker just looks
like a black like a black piece of paper
with white square on it or vice versa
when you hold up to your webcam the
device that you're holding up to your
web cam has a 3d aspect to it so in this
case it's a little Alice in Wonderland
or something so companies that have used
this include best buy GE Walmart Walmart
had a pretty cool thing where teenagers
they were trying to sell furniture
teenagers so they had a piece of print
material that was in magazines and when
teenagers held it up in their room they
could then take different pieces of
furniture and see how it would actually
look in their room so I thought that was
pretty cool is that the logic is you're
in your room and you can see as you move
the magazine around how a piece of
furniture would look IKEA is done
something similar Vodafone who we all
love apparently in terms of the leading
work they're doing a lot of mobile
spaces this is something you've probably
seen a lot s of late and it's in terms
of cities augmented reality one of the
biggest uses early on commercially and
in general is tour guides so there's a
company called layar I got to meet a
couple of them a few weeks ago in
Amsterdam they're based in Amsterdam
right here what you're looking at is
basically just a cell phone or a
smartphone and augmented reality
technically I won't go into all the
technical definitions but it's basically
digital data overlaid other existing
like in this case camera data so this is
a one of the rings and Amsterdam and
seeing it you see these little floating
bubbles so there's GPS technology
there's forget what it's called
ergonomic type stuff so as you actually
move the phone it moves with you and
what this means is you can actually have
a walking step-by-step guided tour of a
city so you start to think about you
know this is kind of fun
in terms of first of all if you don't
speak the language you don't speak Dutch
you get off the plane you for instance
can translate this into English and find
nearby hotels and again when you think
of walking directions from a GPS
standpoint you could pull it out of your
car but now especially if you take a
look at a village here in New York you
know I usually ask people still after
living your a decade like where the hell
is whatever Mott Street you know this
means you can actually take it and walk
step by step so why should all these
people here is this a term now amongst
augmented reality geeks or at least I
love to use it what we call the internet
right if something we're in general
we're doing what I'm doing right now I'm
sort of leaning into a screen right this
is a geeky term called the Outernet and
the logic here now is that besides
physically that you can take your mobile
phone outside of an arena where you need
a pc this is whole realm of data like
Sarah was talking about I usually tend
to call this whole sort of realm the
Internet of Things what that means is
all this data as you walk along etc that
is stored or that can be transferred to
you is for instance a data that would
affect your everyday life so for
instance a big goober geek friend of
mine is named Jack Mason he works at IBM
he talked about one of these sensors
they can be put in a public place it's
RFID mixed with heat sensor data and if
you register with a certain medical
device technology company it for
instance can tell you when you have an
arrhythmia that is incorrect for your
heart and as you're walking for these
different public spaces you can get a
text that basically says I think you
should sit down which if you start if
you start to think about how much this
stuff is interlinked what I'm so
passionate about with augmented reality
is not just the cool 3d stuff but it's
how all this data is converging and long
story short I work in PR right the last
thing I do when I go in and pitch
Gillette or HP or one of our bigger
clients is like so the intense GPS data
location taken out they don't care about
the technology and as a rural consumers
don't either right you call this the
Amsterdam tourist app because that's why
people use it right most technology and
I'm serious still get me wrong if
they're geeky I'll geek out with them of
Lima beer but
terms of like why they're going to use
this it's always about the value
proposition so i'll see if i can get a
video going here because it's such a
visual medium it's really best to show
you video and is the volume back on i
don't know if i can thank you I don't
know
60 meters
so pretty cool stuff for at least those
geeks here what I wanted to show you
that all is again nike is amazing I
thought this video was amazing and
showing you again why you use these
different technologies and there's about
six different pretty big technologies
involved in what you just saw a QR code
is different from an augmented reality
code QR stands for quick response is it
no quick read anyway I'm too sweaty to
remember the exact same but it's QR
something but the difference there is
that basically you can take a picture of
something with your camera just as you
take a picture with that square and then
automatically be directed to URL so
ironically a lot of the work we do at
the firm i work at is with
pharmaceutical companies there's tons
that they cannot do on social media
because of reporting stuff at the FDA
one thing they can do is put these
little black squares on pharmaceutical
bottles so that when you and I go to the
pharmacy again say we are from Tokyo and
don't read English we can see a QR code
that says in Japanese Japanese and you
click on it and read it and you can read
the entire contents of that bottle and
Japanese you can be directed to a video
right so what I'm again really
passionate about is how this connects
with with people and how initially you
can speak to people through this
technology where again all that Linda
dental as a friend says he download this
cool app when you take a picture in the
grocery store you can find out this
information there's another technology
called sticky bits where if you're in a
grocery store you can take a picture of
a barcode of any product and it will
tell you in the nearby area where the
cheapest places to buy that product
right so you start to think about how we
can kind of bastardize other people's
business and that's you know when you
think about like oh that's not a very
you no good reason to use this
technology the point is is I never lyin
eyes you're demonize technology I think
it's always fascinating how people use
it to help or to do bad things and you
work against it all that type of thing
but still it's always fast and see what
they're going to do so anyway this is
the type of technology basically now
with augmented reality for mobile you
hold up your phone right the logic is
this is the type of
you'll see what most people think
however is that you're going to have it
on your glasses very soon like
sunglasses now you may think no way no
freaking way am I going to wear glasses
and look like you know Arnold
Schwarzenegger geek but when you think
about it right now this this is going to
come first of all these glasses are
being designed by companies like vizio
apple has grants in two different
companies for these these glasses will
come they will probably actually be
contact lenses versus glasses but the
early iterations will be these glasses
and you think no way we're going to wear
these but all of us I guarantee you're
right walk around like this you know
through crowded intersections right and
almost died because we're texting
walking through hands-free this data now
means you can see now here's something
facial recognition technology right very
basic mass scale consumer available
facial rectus facial recognition
technology is already here okay so
delineating between like all 80 of you
and knowing where you're from and stuff
right now would be pretty hard but
friends sensitive family of six
different people you know male who's 50
female whose 37 whose whatever that's
that's done we're done but for me those
types of technology things it's just a
question of time till it becomes
ubiquitous it's just iteration to the
technology so for instance what this
says right here which i think is funny
Harold show right so now we're walking
with our glasses five years from now
maybe 10 years from now I'm back here
given the same lecture and in my contact
lenses I want to find people who know
about augmented reality and they've done
a paper on it while I'm talking to you
right now so in my contact lenses while
I'm talking right here I'm doing me to
pick you up but this VM woman would have
pop up you know has a PhD in whatever so
I can know like Oh mrs. Smith nice to
meet you whatever right but I've chosen
that data to see in this case what I'm
fascinated about from a public relations
standpoint is how this technology is
going to change communications within
cities this here says this guy's credits
credit scores 443 someone is tagged him
and said nice guy just don't lend him
any money right so there's a wonderful
futurist if you want to read a
fascinating guy as name is
jahmai Castillo CIS CIO he writes for
Fast Company a lot of great publications
he is this idea that very soon the same
type of technology lets say you hate
republicans you're a democrat and you
hate republicans you wear these glasses
now you walk down the street every
Republican is framed in blue right so
you say pardon my french Bucky I want to
look at you two want to talk to you or
you hate them so much that you make them
into shrubs virtual shrubs and you walk
around them right now it's funny because
it seems extreme it's not think think
right now in terms of GPS when you drive
right you don't go certain routes
anymore or you say i want to see these
restaurants those other restaurants you
don't see a certain level of serendipity
is gone right but now in terms of
choices data fascinating so here's a
couple more things is to give you a
sense of how this technology is used in
cities right now combination of big maps
google maps very simply this is points
of data and again this is if it were
mobile you could click on it yelp
anybody use yelp you probably have seen
this this is a fun app instead of having
to go to a restaurant right like a lot
of people like why I'm gonna use
augmented reality I like they're really
yelp but I'm like well I don't want to
haul my pc and walk around to each
restaurant and stand there and go how
many stars so now I go in front of a
restaurant and I wave my phone and I see
the eight or nine reviews that have come
up and instantly nope I'm not going to
go here nope not going to go here you
start to see how this is going to affect
Commerce you start to see how a shop
owner you have to really make sure this
data is something you you know curate
effectively this I have a bunch of
videos i want to show you i want to
honor our time but this is in tokyo i
think this is fascinating it's hard to
see in this picture this behind this
what you're seeing this is actually a
building and when you hold up this
certain application of this as an iphone
when you hold up the application you act
can actually see in real time what
people are tweeting inside that building
so you start to see again how would that
affect commerce oh there's i do biz dev
for a certain company and
in this building on this floor all these
people are tweeting about a convention I
go to that convention right so a big
thing for me in terms of technology a
lot of people at least in the marketing
world are saying augmented reality is
just a fad it's going away I don't see
augmented reality it's just this tiny 3d
technology like I say it's all these
things that are woven together a bee
when I see certain companies getting
involved in a space that's when I say
hey marketers I don't care don't care
what you're thinking I'm interested in
what Google is doing right so for
instance what Google does we should all
pay attention to you right so they have
this thing called favorite places this
again is QR codes it's not augmented
reality but what this is is they went to
about a thick a thousand businesses in
San Francisco and now all over the
country and said hey do you want to put
this piece of paper this sticker on your
window this this QR code will link to a
specific URL associated with your store
so what you'll see all of her San
Francisco is these signs and now you can
stand outside of a store take a picture
and again kind of like the yelp thing
get a sense of who's reviewed that store
if you ever get a chance it's an amazing
book by a guy named paco underhill
called why we buy it's this scientific
study because I certainly understand the
need for you know scientific rigor with
a lot of my stuff if not all is you know
largely based on passion but an
introspection but this this two or three
foot divide between why you go into a
store or certain space there's literally
like thousands of pieces of data that
get you to go from point A to point B
right so what's Dorner's know is if
you're outside of their store and you
know things like hey here's what's
unspecial here's this here's that here's
these reviews if you walk in after you
take this QR code you'll get a coupon
that when you scan in our barcode
scanner you'll get a discount but also
have more metrics to know more about the
demographics of my customers all this
stuff Google's looking into you
mentioned the Eiffel Tower a minute ago
this is something google has now called
google goggles which is fascinating and
a paradigm shifter in my opinion what
this is is now you hold up your
smartphone to any
location on the planet take a picture of
an immediately Deza virtual virtual
visual search to see who else has taken
a picture of that object right so what
that means is you're in Milan or
wherever and you don't know the name of
a building so you take a picture of it
odds are someone has taken a picture of
that so we'll bring up who's taking a
picture of that now that's already just
kind of cool because you might be like
hey what's this building cool I can tell
my mom yay what is fascinating about it
for me is the idea of visual search data
a lot of my work sometimes very very
dredgers generous very drudgery filled I
don't know the right word is is social
media metrics right there's an art and
science to social media metrics but we
search by keywords keywords as you know
in terms of what Google uses the main
thing when you tag something your blog
your flickr photos etc it's clumsy
because I say the word for instance I
take a picture of my boot that I'm
walking in and I do a blog post about my
boot because we have a client timberland
right a person in the UK reads that blog
or searches under boot and they think
they're looking for good things to put
in their trunk right language is clumsy
right a minute in a bad way but it's
just very general then there's semantic
search visual search is another paradigm
shifter because now when you think about
when you're wearing those glasses that I
talked about and you put in search data
you know somehow through up to your
glasses now you can search visually and
find these different places guaranteed
someone's taking the picture of them to
help you on your journey through the
city so again one thing I don't have
time to show all the videos this is
facial recognition technology that was
developed about a year ago the logic
here is what this guy is done is from in
social networks and this is where
augmented reality and cities helps us to
be more social or more aggressively
social when you point your iPhone at him
what this is is basically a visual
representation of his social networks
that he's showing in the public space so
basically what that means is right now
two years from now three years from now
while I'm talking you probably would
hold up your phone to me take a picture
and see my LinkedIn my LinkedIn bio my
Twitter biol you'd follow my tweets
maybe in real time
this also the video what it shows at the
beginning of it is he's at home getting
dressed and he has his personal external
bio on so when a friend walks down the
street and holds up his phone to him he
sees his myspace page instead of
LinkedIn right so this is very
interesting now in terms of there's a
whole thing called the open ID movement
how we identify ourselves in the real
world that's well as online the book
that I wrote called tactical
transparency entered these guys who
basically created an online way to prove
that you are who you are they created a
fake ID of a Harvard graduate of a woman
I forget her name they call they're like
Susan Smith and within four days they
had 84 links to this woman who was
fictional she was a fictional Harvard
grad and on linkedin within two or three
days they linked you know hey Bob wants
to connect with you hey great i don't
remember Susan from my class but your ad
I knew in the clicked on it right so
again what's fascinating now is how we
identify ourselves and this you can't
really see this is a project that was
done at MIT this is someone wearing a
technology that augmented its augmented
reality but it's also got a projection
component to it so he's projecting tags
on to someone else now this is
interesting because it's at an actual
tag that you and I can see without a
phone but a lot of tagging that's done
now like this is the logic that
augmented reality wise there's a lot of
tools now where I can leave not just
tags associated with a certain physical
space where this bottle is right now I
can leave a tag I can leave a tag on
moving physical objects so in a sense
will become social objects walking
around where we can get tagged this is
just a project that we did it South by
Southwest if you know Robert Scoble he's
a big geek I say that with respect we
did a project called scavenge ayur where
we just did a scavenger hunt using
augmented reality clues as tags and what
Robert said is this idea of social
objects which I thought was quite
interesting he had a t-shirt on that had
an augmented reality coat on it and the
logic here is that people could not only
read like this is a 3d ? way to 3d elvis
and all this stuff they could not only
see that and have fun with it they could
then click and leave a message for
hey Robert great shirt see you tonight
at the party right so tag what is a
social is an augmented reality Network
we're again now a lot of the augmented
reality applications that are out there
now let you hold up your phone and do
something so for instance you can see
the nearest subway in Paris and walk
step by step and that's a great utility
right if you don't know French and you
just want to get home this again now
lets you tag space so you can leave
messages for other people so think about
now two years from now again maybe it's
a different language maybe you're going
to New York and you're totally stoked
and you're going to create a you know a
walking tour for your girlfriend so you
create these tags and say hey Susan make
sure to go here next go here next go
here next these tags aren't visible to
the human eye these are things that
through a cell phone a smart phone you'd
be able to see but again from a sense of
how this is going to change cities I'll
give you some more examples in a minute
but you could think for instance rather
than having to leave a piece of paper
for someone hey connealy this piece of
paper for so-and-so it could be anything
from a crime was committed here so data
can be committed and people can comment
on I witnesses they could just tag you
know you're scared to make a phone call
but you can say hey so-and-so you know I
was here and this guy hit this other
woman here's a picture of it and you can
statue a picture to that physical space
with tagged data so i wanted to show you
just some of the commercial applications
and the reason that augmented reality is
really sticking is things as simple as
shopping this is a winner reality tool
that lets you try on virtual shirts and
this woman these icons are only on the
screen they're not actually in her room
but as she puts the shirt on she can
raise her hand up in actual physical
space and go like this and it registers
that she wants to go on to the next
shirt so it's we're trying a bunch of
different shirts it's obviously a little
bit clunky you're not going to wear like
a gown and uses technology but again
it's pretty fun interactive this is a
similar technology done by Cisco again
when I see massive global organizations
really working on a technology that's
when I say
attention so this is something in store
she's trying on these different clothes
and she's seeing how this dress look and
this is actually a mobile credit card
reader so at the end of the video she
says well great how do I pay for this
and she says you already have so I'm
like maybe you should ask me before you
charge me but when you think about the
ramifications of this for retail if you
studied how retail works first of all
point of sale right that moment of
influence where she's like I don't know
if I want the green and she sees the
blue and she was like oh my god I love
the blue right what do you not want is
this woman oh the blue is in the back
let me take 14 minutes and run and get
it right gone lost the sale she sees the
blue she's bought great can I charge you
I'm sure boom done right supply chain
issues staffing issues the ROI of this
type of technology massive this from a
training perspective this is BMW is
doing of this type of training he's
wearing these geeky goggles right but
what he's looking at is the engine of a
BMW car and he sees a real-time video
happening in his glasses but i should
say it's a real-time interactive video
he's knowing how i think it's a
carburetor he sees how to remove a
carburetor and which tools to use you
know what i think i need to show that
when do you want explaining it i will
mute the music because almost
universally every augmented reality
video has the cheesiest music ever but
you can see again BMW a pretty
significant company investing a pretty
big amount of money in this he puts on
these glasses let's move ahead yes we
see you wearing the glasses but now this
is what he sees right he wants to remove
the yellow thing you can tell him the
mechanic so he sees the tools he's
supposed to use right it's something big
mechanic that the green thing if it uses
the wrong tool it flashes red if he
takes out the wrong thing the flashes
red now keep in mind it's the right
model of the car for the video is using
but it's not like it's a pre done video
of that car so now you start to see and
this technology is being utilized for
medical facilities think about the fact
of your Red Cross worker right and
there's medical technology now for a
child a certain age it's not going to be
there femur that you're looking at but
you'll know putting on these goggles do
this apply pressure here you'll see
digital data in your glasses save that
life right training and think of any
facility we're normally maybe three or
four hours for an entire one whole day
and a manager has to walk someone around
and give a tour the first time someone
comes to work now that you say hip with
the glasses on your chiral take anywhere
from two to five hours depending how
much you want to interact and you can
start to see how that's going to really
affect things as well so this is kind of
fun I have a concept called that I I
kind i think there's seven people who
know it please feel free to spread it
called virtual air rights because when I
first learned about augmented reality
about a year ago sadly one of the first
things I thought is I'm going to go to
Times Square and festoon virtual images
of clients me you know whatever I want
to do and this is something a company's
already started to do that readwriteweb
has done some awesome work Marshall
Kirkpatrick and
in a reality space and what this is this
is a augmented reality app any time you
look at the BP logo it has a pipe that's
bursting and which is pretty funny but
what uh what this guy's jamiah cascio I
interviewed him a number of months ago
what he talked about though is something
similar walking down a grocery store so
say you're a Pepsi fan versus a coke fan
right now when you walk down a grocery
store and you're wearing these glasses
maybe every time a Pepsi logo comes up
or a coke coke logo rather if you don't
like Coke every time a coke logo comes
up all you see your Pepsi products right
so you walk down an aisle I'll explain
this again right all this technology is
there's the technology it's called
markerless technology instead of it
having to be a black X now augmented
reality tags can actually look like this
bottle so if I'm wearing these glasses
and I see this bottle pretend it's a
coke bottle and I hate coke right for
some reason it just hate it now I pick
it up and it says Pepsi now I'm not
going to buy it right it probably will
say like fake Pepsi I don't know it
would say but the point is is that now
what this talks about is trade trademark
infringement right now I can go to any
store in the planet and I can put these
virtual tags up and again festoon with
my product my company's moon to people I
work for there are no set laws yet for
this virtual advertising arena one of
the reasons again this will affect us
soon is Google Maps if you leave your
house right now or I'm sorry if yeah if
you leave your house right now and you
look to your left and you see a
billboard for a certain movie right and
then you go back to that same location
in google maps that billboard is is
space that Google can sell to their
advertisers it's essentially sort of
Google sidebar ads right but if you
start to wear these glasses as you walk
down the street less and less will you
see the real world more and more will
you see the virtual and companies may be
pissed and say I paid for that billboard
and their answer will be you paid for it
in the real world now you have to pay
fees for in the virtual world and we
laugh but news flash Google is doing it
right now
right and if people get pissed and go
what are you doing and they'll say we
own the platform it's called google
right if you don't like it then don't
use google maps right anyway I think
it's fascinating because there it is so
again this is what I call virtual lab
retiring rights this is a product right
now that exists where along with seeing
local subways and parents you can find
the local starbucks with local
McDonald's look or whatever click on it
and go this is a project that was done
in Prague this is technology we can
essentially draw in virtual space so one
thing I want to do is I want to go to
the sheep's meadow in Central Park and I
want to put up a virtual museum maybe
it'll be the john museum I don't know
maybe it'll be something for my kids but
either way I'm going to put it there and
then tell people about it and then see
people walk there and hold their phones
around feel cool this again is something
it's an augmented reality shirt where
this guy is tagged himself all this and
trying to explain that this is just
going to happen it's already happening
now five years from now this wall will
be the dedicated augmented reality wall
right and 42 or you'll probably call it
something different you'll just called a
virtual billboard right so this series
the the icon you know from the hole that
big yellow logo for the thing will be
put up there but you guys stated you
won't have to worry about spending 500
bucks for a big poster you just hang it
up there and then during the conference
I mean during the talk you could post a
lot of things and say hey nice talk
you'll be grading me on my talk with
tags in real time that will go on
Twitter and it will be geared for SEO
and Google I mean I don't need to tell
you that you're going to be doing this
but i'm pretty sure it's going to happen
this is something from a city standpoint
i wanted to get some very City specific
augmented reality stuff they are as a
company that's doing a lot of great work
in Amsterdam there's a technology now
when you go through a city you can see
historical photos of buildings you look
at so if you want to see for instance
what grand central terminal look like
before they tore down in 1908 or
whatever it was you can see actual
historical photos from an architecture
standpoint I'm sure you guys know a lot
more about this side of things than I do
but visualization from an architectural
standpoint
rihanna is being used a lot so what this
means is say you may want to buy
something that's a consumer you might
want to buy an apartment building and
when you go to the spot because you're
still building it all you see is dirt
and ground right this lets you visualize
what will that apartment building look
like when it's when it's built this I
won't play the video but this is a neat
installation that was all over the world
Caroline the movie Caroline where
Carolyn if we go is pronounced she's
button eyes this is an interactive 3d
artistic installation in a shop window
but it follows these women right so it
sort of stalks you the eyes stock you
but then there's a different
installation that projects buttons onto
your eyes so the logic here is this next
screen over you can't see it you see
yourself but you see the core lean
buttons put over your eyes and the
screen this is somebody's found this
morning it blew me away my wife was kind
of bored about it but that's ok in
amsterdam and rotterdam apparently
there's a lot of and i'll just show this
apparently there's a lot of crime
against local yeah here we go I look
service in place
so from a city perspective the reason
this blew me away and again in terms of
the work I do for social medium public
relations more and more influence is
about either entertainment or involving
someone in an event and in this case
what I find so fascinating is these
people see themselves doing something
they normally do they normally would
stand there and watch them and get beat
up apparently right but now there they
are it's pointed out to them hey hey
you're standing there watching someone
get beaten up what if that was you what
if that was your wife or your child so
and the blue screen yeah it's always
funny here but dumbass take a picture I
think at the end of it it goes here and
says so then it gives messages of what
to do right this is where I think from a
city standpoint that starts to get
really interesting ask others for help
speak out together stay with the victim
make photos
so I'm wrapping up i'm almost done here
this is cool i tweeted this guy today
because he started following me on
twitter this is one of the more advanced
technologies that we're working on this
I'll just show you general motors if
they can stay around long enough to make
this technology work this is another
fascinating thing from the city
standpoint this is an augmented reality
windshield so inside the windshield as
you drive the sensor data lets you know
a half mile ahead a mile ahead there's
an accident well before you could see it
with the human eye one thing I want to
show you is this very freaky looking
correct but what this is in terms of the
contact lenses I talked about before and
there's so much so many great like
cyberpunk novels if you ever want to
read like William Gibson neuromancer
Minority Report which you've probably
seen but when when we I'll just say I'll
just be bold and say this when we are
wearing our augmented reality or digital
contact lenses and say five or 10 years
from now these I movements will help
direct it's basically going to replace
this or my mouse you can't see that it
will rip it out of the machine instead
of a malice right we're walking along
and I'm talking to you in normal mode
right I move my eye to the right for two
seconds and the digital mode comes up
while I'm talking to you I'm a bit like
this again its preset to something like
show me people's social channels I don't
know so boom then I love your head would
appear all your social channels and I
can go like this and click my head this
is the same type of technology the logic
here is that where people are looking in
the windshield is also something like
for instance if they look to the left
and this object half mile ahead is going
to hit them maybe there give me a
direction that says warning and a
flashing light will bring their eyes
back forward so again one one
application my buddy from IBM talked
about which blew my mind is because now
video data storage you can store so much
Matt Nina's so much data in one place
both my grandmother's sadly had
Alzheimer's disease and it really sucked
too
then you know go through that dementia
we're especially when they got to that
point where they knew they were
forgetting who you worked sucked right
so think about facial recognition
combined with massive storage data if my
grandmother if I'd walked into the room
and on her glasses she saw this is your
grandson John hey John she doesn't
actually have to remember that I'm John
or boom you haven't eaten go eat right
and there's little lights that lead her
to her cabinet and tell her what to eat
right this is this technology is here
now it's just not ubiquitous it's not
necessarily affordable right think about
this every interaction that we probably
will have again five ten years from now
video storage is so cheap I have a
conversation with David here for ten
minutes after we're done I record it and
five years from now I'm walking around
and I say you know I press the button
that says bring up video footage or show
who I have video saved about and it and
look around and David happens to be at
South by Southwest across the aisle so
it pops up and says david i think i
don't remember david sorry about you
know and it plays back and rewinds to
this this night and plays back the ten
minutes of our interaction together
right we can start storing that much
video data and again if you're suffering
from dimension dementia etc you can
remember hey this morning you did this
afternoon you this yep all right almost
done parking suppose he how much parking
using RFID at San Francisco I think
about this if you were driving to work
and there's ten spots that are coveted
you really need that spot on your
dashboard it can say hey there's eight
spots left you want to buy it you say
you click yes it charges you five bucks
for that spot by your your credit card
then when you get to your spot instead
of going around that one extra time you
park right who benefits you're psyched
because you get to park in a spot the
city benefits because they get that
extra five bucks and you just not going
around the block one more time say it's
a certain amount of carbon
negative carbon emissions if you think
about this type of stuff amplified to a
new york city how smart parking could
you know drastically affect negative
carbon emissions pretty exciting this is
a similar technology where you can
actually see carbon dioxide levels this
is something pretty basic but this is a
path leading you to add or during a fire
you may think well that's not that sexy
well this is now completely covered in
smoke you're holding up your phone and
what you're seeing is the path that's
according to the plans of that building
think about firefighters going into some
going into a place where it's
pitch-black or there's so much smoke
they can't see what there is is floor
plans house with the city that they can
know every building that you know has
been registered and they can say you're
going into 11th smith street and they
will see the path of where things should
be now of course if you've moved your
bathroom or something that may be
screwed but you get the idea this is my
buddy jack who i talked about is in uber
geek i'll end with this this is where
we're going to be in a couple of years
i'll let you read it
so I love this because II harmony
there's already a couple of augmented
reality dating services and that's
essentially what this is that means if
you were registered with the harmony and
wanted to meet a man or a woman of a
certain type and you were at a bar you
could turn on a button that says where
the local a harmony i'ts or whatever and
it'd be like oh she's across the bar OOP
and here's her likes and dislikes this
is going to drastically this is paradigm
shifting this isn't just a cool neat
technology all this stuff converging is
a cultural shift my son who's seven can
now pick up women in a geeky way right
because in his contact lenses he's going
to see oh hey she friended me a week ago
and I didn't know who she was on Twitter
and oh I look over here and LinkedIn but
moving Mike to the left and she likes
blues music so do I know she hates it
when guys try to pick her up at bars
because i read a blog post i wrote two
weeks ago like that and he goes okay I
know she likes coffee I'll meet her at
starbucks tomorrow and I know from data
that she's allowed people to see that
she goes to this starbucks through
blocks away so I'll just happen to be
there when she shows up and I'm buyer a
latte right this is I'm kind of hyper
belies enfora fecht but it's here and
this is just a sort of freeform thing I
did in terms of the types of experiences
that will have but anyway there it is
some people worry that will have a
landscape advertisers will litter will
have visuals BAM that's what that's
about if you want to ask me where I'm at
a time but i'm working with a couple of
guys jack from IBM we have a sort of a
movement it's not really a company
called out or next instead of Outernet
because we're both excited and concerned
about where some of this technology will
go especially in terms of privacy I have
kids I don't want you to know certain
data about my kids and you should be
allowed to choose like on facebook
that's been a lot of difficulties you
know most people don't understand their
privacy data and that's it
alright thanks so much to all our
speakers I know in the interest of time
we kind of went a a bit over I did want
to ask each speaker to come down if any
of you had any questions i was going to
open it up just directly to you are
there any questions from the audience
yeah could be chief of speakers come
good right
I see it good they're very live these
are very light I think it's like any
technology it's about your choice you
know three years ago people would say
140 characters I tell you what sandwich
I eat that's your crazy and now people
have understood that beyond it just
being Twitter being a tool that you can
talk about you've done is a great
business development tool it's geotagged
its cultural to your point it's very
social very mood focus etc again
technology I try not to lionize or
demonize it like I said you may decide
you want to have only you don't want to
see homeless people you just want to see
shrubs what's going to be fascinating to
me is when it becomes mandated you know
when certain companies may say because
of my intellectual property rights I
will not allow you to walk down a
grocery store and only see Pepsi versus
coke what's going to be tough though is
I don't know how they're going to
mandate it because it's my device I walk
into that grocery store you can't tell
me what to do on my device so i don't
know if that's answering your question
well why i'm fascinated about it is that
it i think there's a huge amount of
positive things with these this
convergence and technologies medical
teaching all that stuff i mentioned but
there's just as many things to be wary
of virtual spamming people ignoring
cultural interactions so i think it's
it's like any major technology it's like
the internet right ten years ago or nine
years ago or eight years ago people
might say do you think the Internet is a
good thing and the answer now would be
what do you say
working okay that far you know I
remember in the mid-90s when people talk
about you know virtual reality
architecture rendered obsolete
physicality was somehow in crisis and
materiality was not cool and so
architect sort of like totally digital
digital studio paperless Studios right
here and there was a Sephora over the
kind of the loss of like report and it
was also kind of read a lot of philip k
dick reading a lot of Gibson you know
there were there were science fiction
sort of projections about a post
corporeal world and then they're
released Incredibles or reactions to
them there's incredible know where the
bodies
notice now that he's repulsed by the
smell of a certain separating it you
know that sort of mid 90s Borya prices
I think what the difference between
virtual and augmented
mented you know it's not an either/or
choice it's another layer it's another
and I think what we're interested in as
interaction that remaining of media or
information and physical material I
think you guys are going to be working
with different tools that will allow you
to modify the physical material space in
the world of good information that's the
exciting future for architecture is not
about visualizing geometries affecting
the world physical
world
next question
this is a really loose question but if
you guys could have your way what sort
of legislation isn't really the right
word but you know when the internet was
was founded there were series of
standards and so what do you think if
you had your way you would implement on
that sort of a global perhaps national
scale to do unified things would it be
you know just one virtual world or what
yes that's for everybody or anybody who
wants to answer I think again this guy
Jack who I'm talking about like he's my
geek dad but he kind of is you know IBM
at some of the earliest social computing
guidelines well before most social media
policies and it's like this three page
thing you can still find online where
they talk about how it's mainly for IBM
employees because they did a lot of the
leading work in second life so that it's
pretty cool like you know at my firm the
social media policy is about 10 or 11
points it's relatively nuanced but it's
stuff like in your Twitter bio
acknowledge that you work for PR firm
right so my name you'll see my twitter
bio working this is in second life
acknowledge that your avatar works for
IBM if you know if asked so what's
pretty cool about that is it gives a
good sense of where are you and who are
you and so I think for me the main thing
i would want is first of all you i don't
think you can uniformly dictate globally
you know privacy issues there's two sort
of european mores versus the states i
think what's critical and Facebook is it
great you know that they are the biggest
website on the planet period that's a
fact right right now I think it's like
sixty percent of people don't understand
how to use the privacy settings on
facebook it's not a question of what
they do it right or wrong they don't
understand about them right so I think
the main thing I would want this outer
next thing that we started which would
be happy to have you join really all you
do is click on the wiki write something
but is that people are educated about
this these different technologies and
all this all this data like you know if
you don't know it it's funny that people
are scared about like oh I'm worried
about foursquare go wall up I don't want
to let people know
like well look if you haven't even a
basic cell phone not a smartphone you
know through GPS technology you know
take the battery out and turn off or
else someone's gonna be able to know
where you are so I think education is
the main thing about like if you want to
share this data when you're kind of a
public persona then turn into a when you
want to try not to have certain data
shown I don't want a google maps show in
my house you know I think I think we're
in an era where people really don't get
privacy and that's one of the reasons
there at that book transparent the tax
code transparency so I think the main
thing I want to do is educate people and
make sure that they have options very
clearly delineated for what they can
choose that makes
build it out
hello ok so the potentials beyond the
spoken word 24 sort of universal
exchange of information what do you
think that does then to the social
sphere and interaction among people do
we communicate solely through image
exchange I mean is this conversation
we're having even possible in the future
I mean of course we can all speak but if
its preferred to communicate through
imagery what happens to the social
exchange
I think that I think we're probably just
diversified social change means
something different but we're still
going to talk to each other the easiest
way to communicate right I don't think
we're going to eliminate that certain
kind of communication or described a
diversifier multitasker becomes crazy
multitaskers where our way of
communicating or speaking also involves
kind of flips whips text video
but I think that it doesn't eliminate
the tip of interaction we're having now
claimed that
write a handwritten letter kind of a
thank you note today means more than ten
years ago so it's I think that's right
it's diversify sore the set of channels
you can I guess on the Eli to send the
text call a good facts but sometimes you
want to send the text you don't want to
call we don't want that awkwardness FX
which is seven more choices now learn to
choose which ones are more appropriate
than the ones at the right moment if you
wrote i had written thank you letter
really special and very selectively
so I think it's just going to shift
values
I don't think
crystal I don't want any of you talking
to me ever again I'm skid don't talk to
me the future I agree with both of you
guys I'll play the futurist card and say
that I think what's going to be
interesting is who we decide to talk to
is that's what's going to change like
now I did biz dev for a couple years of
my last company and you know I had to
look at someone's name tag and be like
oh I really wanted Bob work with Sara at
Columbia and I'd have to see are you
attending the conference if I even was
given that information and then I'd have
to see on your name tag and then I have
to stalk you right to try to talk to you
right that's that was my job to stalk
people professionally in a good way now
I go to a conference five years from now
actually been now this year in South by
Southwest there were QR codes and our
tags write my name tag so within a
couple years I'm going to look around a
room say you were all here and what I
need to reach is a CMO or someone who's
a vp of marketing and there are two of
you I sweep the room like that I know
who I have to talk to right so the
dynamic of who we choose to talk to I
think will drastically change and I
think how we choose who we speak to
again I think about GPS when I think to
myself like no this can't happen this
won't change and how many of you looked
at a map when you drive anybody how many
of you would know how to use a map if
you if you were stuck my son is going to
look at a map and yeah Sean my buddy
Sean the back give it them but it's the
same type of thing I think the GPS model
is a very interesting one to follow in
terms of how we select off' i keep using
words that don't exist but Shakespeare
made up his own words how will you
select who you're going to talk to
that's what's going to change
you also knowing that change the way
that you behave right so like if these
become really popular
you know like I'm not put on my CV I
would almost be better as a black person
problems with more of a system I mean I
think I think that the way that we
advertise ourselves would totally change
the one of the tricky things with that
actually just because I read all these
tech blogs to somebody work is one of
the growing trends in it and then I'll
just reputation management and it's not
what you post about yourself it's what
everyone in this room posted about you
and that's available in the QR code so
how do people start to track that and to
your question about who you talk to
there's an interesting foursquare mashup
that tracks where people are that you
don't want to see so you don't go to
those bars because they check in and
that's all that person's at that bar on
whether tonight and it's already then
that's already happening
next I was going to say United talked
about the nature public realm you know
because I'm interested in cities and
physical cities as well and you know the
question about you know what is public
space and who is the public and how is a
public constructed and how does it sort
of present itself in public with the
decorum of the public realm that you
would have is different from your
bedroom I think with these these news or
channels are opening up there are other
means of broadcasting you are ready
broadcasting you put on your clothes do
your hair you're presenting an image now
you're sort of extending that sort of
constructed self image into another
meeting
and just have to do your hair you have
to do your area to maintain lots more
sort of channels but they are still
still an ocean of public you know and i
think that's still true regardless of
medium whether it's physical interaction
or whether
that's that's interesting we did a
project for pharmaceutical company that
wanted to develop a new lab space and
said how do you design a space for
innovation and the dem I teeth at
something people are interested in have
you as architects create better
education and we interviewed a number of
scientists and they said you know what
sometimes innovation happens through a
chance encounter you know I ran into
sets of scientists and the elevator my
wait in my office you know what how do
we sort of script those and characters
into the architectural circulations so
that scientists are meeting each other
having those conversations having those
potentially breakthroughs I mean it's
pretty mundane but i think it is some of
the people are thinking about how
architecture produces those encounters
and how do i do we as architects or a
script those circulatory paths to
maximize
encounters hoping to produce this moment
I think serendipity could be engineered
Oh
one thing you just said fascinated me
you said something effective with phone
numbers that I remember any phone
numbers and that's okay with phone
numbers but the reason okay okay that in
terms of you're dealing with it that's
funny in terms of what I thought you
were going for there was that it's okay
to if you were saying this we've
forgotten like I'm like you you know I'm
41 I used to know I think it like 30
phone numbers my son will never have to
know that many phone numbers and I'm
sure that someone here can probably tell
me technology medical otherwise about a
certain lobe of brains now that won't
get developed with certain mathematical
skills truly because we can't memorize
nine or ten digit numbers I think that
it's not really an argument it's just a
fact what now does your brain have space
for it and and this is I'm not a
cognitive like therapist or my dad's a
psychiatrist but what is the space now
available for what's the sort of hard or
soft the hard drive I think it really is
whether it's a purist or a technologist
or whatever else you know I would say
one thing is I hope for your stress you
know like some things you just gotta
accept you know like you may not want to
watch shows by a tebow but maybe you
want to skip ads right most people would
say add suck I want to fast-forward them
so buying a tee but there might unstress
you because you don't want ads I don't
mean you i mean one but you know the day
that your choice is completely taken
away from you i agree that's really sad
in terms of all these technologies these
glasses making all these choices for you
is it a concern oh yeah it's a huge one
of mine that's why i'm fascinated by
because I think a lot of these things
that people do they just go cool I put
this box in my car and I never have to
read a map again sweet what if I program
your GPS to always drive an extra
quarter a mile because i work for a gas
company oil company rather and i want
you to spend that extra i'm not of money
on gas maybe the gps people have a deal
with BP all right maybe they do I don't
know is it a concern sure but it's like
saying you know if you want to get
concerned about technology even you know
when books were first introduced you can
read you know when the printing press
first came about there was this great
uproar with certain you know priests and
whatever else like this technology will
destroy minds and it's true all right
it's true you know porn whatever out
started coming to play mass whatever
else and that was a technology at the
time that really threw people off so for
me I think the education about you
knowing this bugs you don't use it you
know you have to put contact lenses in
into your eyes
well it'd be hard to operate it without
it you've got a good point no I'm
serious your your true but one thing is
that like certain things addition to
like wiki's like I love you guys met
wiki's are it's a website that you can
go to multiple people can change an
update and iterate in one space there's
a lot of companies like base camp that
have sort of you know in terms of
time-saving if you use wiki's companies
that have studies it like it would say
forty to sixty percent of your day
because you think about one email i can
resend around a word document hey make
change this document and by the time
that the freaking thing comes back t
it's 80 emails later right there's
certain technologies that also for some
reason people don't the dots don't know
why they just don't but you know you
have a point you betta to disadvantage
but it's also like saying I hate cars so
I'm going to walk over where I hate
planes I'm not going to fly you can make
those choices some people do I was
thinking about this essay by walter
benjamin the work of art in the age of
mechanical reproduction if we haven't
read it you should and you will
inevitably but he talks about
architecture and you talked about
architecture and art and the differences
between the two art is experienced in
the gallery typically it's experienced
when you're
when you're looking for art your senses
are sort of attuned to look for art and
to perceive difference and subtlety
architectures experience in the public
realm and he says it it's experience in
the state of distraction and this is
Walter Benjamin writing in the 1930s
distraction was already an issue of
concern for him he talks about the
religion politics and aesthetics in the
1930s how does aesthetics become
politicized how does attention become an
economy and I think what what you guys
are talking about is you know attention
attention span distraction cognition
these are these are new territories for
design they're being polluted maybe
they're being colonized these
territories that you're inevitably going
to work in you know as architects you're
putting something in the public realm
that has a message Ozil for attention
with all these other medium and I think
it means that your job is architects is
more important how you design forum
physical form and the real world as it
competes with all this other stuff it is
an issue and I think it's a challenge to
take up but it's not a new issue it's
been an issue since probably like a
light bulb you know the invention of me
on the Billboard the large you know
printing press
um to follow the follow Eric's comment I
actually want to ask the question how do
you think all these technology will
affect the role of Architects because
you know 10 years from now I can
probably put a graffiti virtually on any
sign of building and make fun of that
kind of white flag aesthetic or i can
probably convert the entire manhandling
to just white boxes you know this kind
of virtual gentrification is not
governed yet so I can basically do
anything to it it's that um advantage to
you or do you think um architects just
become more vulnerable when the virtual
world is taken over by the public and
what I don't care on that note like how
does academia adjust for this like you
know architecture school in particular
since we're in one people that teach
maybe not Josh and I but have been
around for a while and they don't engage
these sort of things so how do you get
them to learn about these things and
kind of teach for these types of
potential issues or had or to take
pendulum I can gauge them
feel like you know Colombia has been
sort of on the cutting edge of so much
adoption of Technology both in
architecture and other fields I feel
like you know the first paperless
studios were taught here by young
architecture faculty that we're seeing a
new frontier in modeling
representational software I think you
know you to ignore it at your peril you
know I think Columbia became the premier
sword architecture school in the
mid-nineties because it was taking up
these issues and studios work paperless
they were taking on these issues coming
to that Keller review here and I didn't
know what to say because you know it was
so sore out of you know out of nowhere
he was talking about stuff that now is
so common he was taking the material of
this new culture and making it the
substance of two studios and that was
the mid-90s and that was kind of
exciting that's what columbia was known
for I think now that you know
visualization digital label pouria has
sort of receive it a little bit and it's
been replaced with other kind of
excitements other possibilities digital
fabrication to renew materializations of
are now sort of more interesting I do
think the interactions between the two
are the most interesting territory is to
look at as academics how do you make
these old guys relevant how you make the
young guys sort of I don't think it's a
thing as a choice i think you know
people will take up areas of
Investigation areas of research because
it's the most promising I think it would
be a shame if they forgot about how to
design physical stuff and I don't think
that'll ever happen you know that all
for all the paper the studio's taught
here we still have to make and still go
home and sleep on hard surfaces you know
the tact I think there was a question
about the sensorial you know there was a
kind of prejudice towards optical and I
think something like that was also
concerned in the mid-90s like we're
going to lose our bodies we're not going
to be able to smell anymore that's such
a false choice you know and I
these kind of sensorial environments are
of territories for architects have take
on they have been they will be and
they'll continue to be but now we're
responsible for more than just five
senses now we have to design things in
the world that have other layers and I
think it's exciting it's super exciting
it's not it's not something to be afraid
of everything there's something to be
challenged to be taken up and not to say
i'm only going to deal with would
position tectonics position for you i'm
only going to deal with these geometries
messy dirty
yeah I couldn't agree more with a messy
dirty of space in the middle idea I
think it's one of the most exciting
times to be alive to be honest in the
sense of I'm ever years ago as an actor
when I did temp work did a lot of
transcription work and it was when the
internet was first really coming into
play that's how old I am and somebody on
this panel I remember this panel kept
saying someone would say something well
you know IBM it's going to be doing
whatever and the person kept saying calm
calm sort of joking that why don't you
just add dot-com to everything because
this internet thing these tubes are
probably going to take off you know and
we laugh about it now but that the
internet coming into play now is utterly
transformed our lives never going back
this digital era to your point you can't
really avoid physical space I don't see
that happening for a while you know you
can't not eat you know even if you
choose intravenous you know I do think
it's a little bit scary I think you can
alter your consciousness enough that
sensorial stuff could be pretty whacked
pretty pretty fast you know the Bruce
Willis movie that came out recently
service was it surrogate surrogate see I
was really bad but interesting in terms
of you know having a host body but one
thing I would say too is like as an
actor for years I had to fight my way in
New York to get auditions to get an age
of the night a fight to get any casting
directors office and then I had to fight
to get parts when I became involved with
social media when I was delighted with
the sort of anarchist side of things is
now anybody who had their own blog
podcast whatever who had their own voice
could compete in one sense with big
media I think as an architect i would
say rather than make it this negative
like competition it's this amazing
glorious opportunity you know i think
what's going to change is a the
different mediums and i hope you would
use all of them because i'm certainly a
purist like of you have to know how to
like if you're if you want to do motive
but motor stuff you have to now to fix
an engine with a wrench as well as that
BMW thing or you're screwed when your
glasses break
and lose business right so I think I'm
not an architect so I don't mean to
speak sort of as a layman here but I
think the other thing to remember is
that no one will ever not to sound kind
of ABC afterschool especially you would
remember those either but um no one's
ever going to replace the vision you
have meaning the vision that's in your
head and so if you are architecting
mainly in the visual arena sweet do it
if you do want to mainly build homes and
you are more into physical space awesome
do that do it the best way you can but
just be aware that the one thing that's
going to be different is now you can be
so hyper niche in your work that six
people in Tunisia a guy in Thailand
Amsterdam seven people they'll all like
your work and that's now we can find
each other to that level that's what's
going to change things and I think
that's what's going to be long rambling
answer except to say mainly to take away
from me is all this technology for me is
still you you have to embrace kind of
who you are and and put it out there to
the world and just trying to find a good
way to end this was something that's at
least mildly memorable but you know I
think it's a really seriously it's a
really exciting time because you just
have more mediums to work with to do
your art and your architecture
structure and facilitate infrastructure
we're going to know where are they today
what they like to do with see where
there's a pothole we're going to know
demographics age groups all kinds of
information which can help us plan for
places but I think there is reason to be
concerned how we use this data to plan
for places because I think there is a
possibility of marginalizing certain
population certain populations that
aren't active of these devices could
there be kind of a generalization of
those people who don't use the
technology to tell us that there's a
pothole I just did a project using
there's all this 311 information Ella
when you call 311 they log about
information fire acta micronet
now there's a crowdsourcing sites with
2311 well there are certain populations
that just don't know that they can
complain about their city as a part of
their ethnicity or maybe they're poor
they don't think people who listen to
them there's a whole number of reasons
and I was analyzing that data and I said
there's no trash problems in the Bronx
according to the data according to 31
date so that means that the services so
the 311 people are analyzing that data
and say where do we need better services
we need better services well in the
upper east side that's where the hot
spot is this trash trash this huge
problems out for you side not in the
broth not in Brownsville so I think like
we do need to keep in mind how data is
being processed and use and the biases
and I think that's why I kind of talked
about some what kind of advice is
involved
is that there's huge biases and there's
a huge possibility of marginalized
people i think that we need you to them
mine as we use these to make better
efficient cities and you know in the 50s
there's a huge movement to make cities
more efficient right and that's why we
have these big highway certain
communities well if we aren't thinking
about it i think you could have huge
highways dividing our virtual virtual
space really got that yeah i really want
to get out I mean commanding like my
kind of last shopping thing is that you
guys are archetypes your designers
that's why you come to school to design
and this is all just stuff you can use
to design so and I don't think I need
one you need to do hindered constrained
by scared by it these are just new tools
and new information that you can use to
further your argument to me alright well
thanks to our speakers
coming